good evening the boss of Jacky and Land
Rover has issued a stark warning today
over the dangers of what he called a bad
brexit deal British biggest car
manufacturer said a No Deal scenario
could cost him more than a billion
pounds and put tens of thousands of jobs
at risk addressing the zero emission
vehicle summit in Birmingham the Prime
Minister tried to reassure the motor
industry with a pledge to invest more
than 100 million pounds for battery and
low-carbon technology well earlier spoke
to jl arse chief exactly France Beth and
began by asking him about the challenges
the industry faces over the mass rollout
of electric vehicles in the UK electric
vehicles and the rollout of the Masters
means also two elements first of all it
has to be achievable so the price tag
has to be lower at the moment electric
vehicle based on the high prices from
for the internal electrified propulsion
system the prices are too high and
secondly it means convenience we need
more charging stations at the moment the
UK is round about 17,000 and only 1700
they are a fast charging DC charges
obviously the Jackie O ipace is being
built in Austria at the moment because
you didn't have the capacity here in the
UK can you ever see a position where you
actually will be building electric
vehicles here in the UK the IPAs is
indeed the very first premium that's
reelected to be actually in the market
and it shows that a small team that in
the UK there is a creativity to do
something special
and yes I can see that we will also
produce better electric vehicles in the
UK if the conditions are right if we get
a good productivity if we have the right
let's say environment to invest again in
the UK you said in July that's a bad
brexit deal as you turned it would cost
you 1.2 billion pounds it's not still
your view yes it is and by the way it's
quite open
everybody can calculate this kind of
figure and by the way 1.2 billion only
means just four check your land row but
without any burden of the supply
industry and so it's a huge figure and
it's really a challenge for check wheel
and roll at the end of the day that 10
10 thousands of people are on risk if
you don't find a good solution the right
solution for paraxial you're just about
to start production of the discovery in
Slovakia does that Slovakian investment
represent in any way a hedge against a
heart per exit at the end of the day we
are British be an absolutely suppressed
company and we want to stay here
that is our hope on the other hand we
have to have an operational footprint
around the world and so it's important
that the next step to Europe the market
which represents around the turn around
about 25 percent of all ourselves that
we are closer to customers and therefore
we are filled up and will inaugurate the
new plant end of September do you worry
about your supply chains in the event of
an Odile brexit could there be potential
blockages if there were just the name
and very very concerned
we are producing around about 3,000
vehicles in the UK and that means we use
on a daily basis around about 25 million
parts and they come just in time so if
one part is not at the right time on the
right position next to the assembly line
we are facing a challenge and that would
mean if I have stopped the production
it's everyday 60 million pounds and in
terms of the brexit deal that the Prime
Minister wants with the EU are you
satisfied with her checkers proposals at
the end of the day I cannot tell you
what kind of details are in the checker
proposal but I can turn it around and
say what we really need is in principle
free Oh frictionless straight for pots
but also for people we need the skills
on the one hand side we need the lorry
drivers and we need services so that we
can really also produce the vehicles
that the with thyroid means and what
would be your message to those members
of mrs. May's own party who are
threatening to vote down the checkers
proposals I don't know what alternative
they are really proposing and I'm not
political so I cannot give these people
an answer I only can repeat we need free
and fair trade we export more than 80%
of our vehicles and it's not only check
your Land Rover and I don't talk about
Jagger Landro or about myself it's a
question of the people in the country
it's a question of manufacturing they
have to think about the people in
manufacturing they have to also accept
that the UK cannot live wrong financial
services and/or services alone we need
manufacturing in this country some of
the supporters of brexit have argued
that jlr would actually benefit from a
No Deal brexit because you'd be able to
import car parts from around the world
on WTO terms just as easily she would do
currently from the EU
and I don't know how this would work but
I can tell you we don't benefit from any
percocet which is hard or no percocet
whatsoever